let's now get some practice estimating
multiplying with decimals so first year
we have 7.8 times 307 is approximately
equal to what when you see the squiggly
equal sign that means approximately
equal to 1 what so pause this video and
see if you can figure out on your own
alright so the way that I would think
about doing it even if I was trying to
do this in my head at the supermarket or
something I'd say well okay this is I
probably need paper to do this properly
but gee seven point eight is awfully
close to eight and 307 is pretty close
to 300 so maybe I can estimate this by
multiplying eight times 300 now this
isn't going to be exact it's definitely
going to be off but it's gonna give me a
good sense of roughly what 7.8 times 307
is so what is 8 times 300 well 8 times 3
is 24 and so 8 times 300 would be 2400
we got these two more zeroes two more
zeroes and so there you have it and
luckily the people who wrote this
question estimated in a very similar way
to people when they estimate might not
get the exact same answer but in this
case we happen to let's do another
example so here we're trying to estimate
ninety-nine point eight seven times 19
so pause the video again and see if you
can come up with the what a good
estimation alright so once again not
easy to do this in your head but this 99
and 87 hundredths is pretty close let me
do this in a new color this is pretty
close to 100 times and I could multiply
a hundred times 19 that's actually not
so difficult so for example I could say
100 times 19 is equal to 1900 but notice
we don't see that choice here we could
say look 1900 is definitely much closer
to 2,000 than any of these other so that
might be a good approximation now how
did they get 2,000 well they rounded
both of these numbers they said this is
approximately 100 times 20 so it's not
that it's not that it's the right thing
to do to round this 19 up to 20 if you
could do 100 times 19 this is actually
gonna give you a slightly more accurate
result
than doing a hundred times 20 but 100
times 20 is even easier
to estimate in your head but either way
the closest choice here and that's why I
guess these had to be multiple choice
questions is mm let's do another example
so here we are asked to multiply two
point two one times five point one and
we want to know what it approximately
equals so once again we are estimating
so pause this video and try to figure it
out well we're just going to do the same
thing we did in the last two examples
two point two one and well first of all
this is hard to do in my head and so two
point two one
well that's approximately if I round to
the nearest two or to the nearest one I
should say this is going to be two times
five which is equal to ten so this would
be approximately equal to ten and that
is a choice now some of you might say
well there's wet ways to get better
estimations that you could still do with
your head so for example you could say
that this is pretty close to this is
approximate let me do it over here this
is approximately equal to two times five
point one this is still pretty
straightforward to do in your head this
would be ten point two and so but you'd
still say that this is by far the
closest one or you could even say
something like this is approximately
equal to two point two times five what
is this going to be equal to well two
times five is ten and two tenths times
five is another hole and so this is
going to be equal to eleven so all of
these might be things that you could
estimate that you might be able to do in
your head but the important thing to
realize is however you do it by far ten
is going to be the closest response to
what you're getting at and ten would be
a very natural estimation if you try to
simplify both of these numbers when
making that estimate